tens of thousands of soldiers and heavy
weaponry
the russian buildup on the border to
ukraine looks more like preparations for
invasion than the standard military
exercise that russia
claims it's conducting it is the most
massive show of force since russia's
2014
annexation of crimea since then
russia has been deploying mercenaries
volunteers and local collaborators to
wage hybrid warfare in eastern ukraine
now kiev along with europe and the us
fear a dramatic escalation in violence
nato and europe are urging russia to
stand down
we ask russia-ukraine crisis what
does putin want
[Music]
hello and welcome to the point it's a
pleasure to welcome our guests
gesina donbloot is a freelance
journalist who has reported extensively
on and from russia for german public
broadcasters
she says we have seen it all before the
kremlin triggers an escalation
then blames the west but moscow is the
aggressor and there
must be consequences and
i'm very glad to welcome alexander he's
an author and analyst who
also does political consulting for
russian firms including gaspam
he says the phone call between
presidents biden and putin
helped to de-escalate the crisis and
avoid a possible full-blown
conflict and joining us virtually from
dw's
bond bureau is my colleague roman
gonciarenko
he's an editor in our russian department
and was born
in the ukraine region of what was then
the soviet union
he says russia is using bullying tactics
to press ahead with its creeping
annexation of donbass
ukraine must stay calm
so let me begin by asking all three of
you whether you think this is mostly
just
rattling or indeed something more and
because in adornblut your opening
statement certainly suggests you see a
very real danger of a russian offensive
well not necessarily i think it's stable
wrestling and it's uh
yeah directed uh for impressing the west
it's a signal to the west and to
president zielanski from ukraine
and um it's uh yeah i think russia is
trying to
build up the stakes in order to have a
better position
for uh further yeah um
what is for han for negotiation
negotiations
about the eastern ukraine exactly as a
negotiating card
you also said in your opening statement
that there must be consequences
but the kremlin says look we have every
right to move our forces within
our own territory these forces are still
on russian territory
what would you say to that yeah that's
not exactly true because within the osce
there are mechanisms
and they oblige every participant and
every member state
to make transparent if you have such
movements of troops
especially close to your neighbor's
countries
so this is only this is not true
and the consequences i think the west
should send a clear message
a very clear and united message towards
moscow that moscow is the aggressor and
they
stand in solidarity with ukraine
thank you very much alexander your
opening statement referred to the call
between
biden and putin in which biden
apparently offered to meet with putin
sometime in the next couple
of months so would you say this is
mostly about testing the new us
president
i think it's a sincere wish of biden and
probably and hopefully
putin to meet together look in
each other into the eyes tackle the
problems
and try to escalate because the also the
russian side fully understands
that the key for some kind of stable
relations between the west and russia
lies not in brussels not in berlin and
not in paris but in washington
and in order to negotiate on the future
of european security architecture
on everything you have to talk to the
american president
and biden also understands and i think
he has a lot of suppor
of of of consultants who are telling him
this don't
drive russia into the arms of china the
main adversary of the united states is
china not russia
and here biden wants to tackle of course
the problems with putin find out
how how far he can go in order in indeed
to escalate
or in turn to do then confrontation also
with russia
i assume that you followed russian media
after this
phone call uh they uh some at least
suggested it was a real climb down by
biden
what makes you think that the call had a
de-escalating effect
uh for moscow well
one thing is what the some kind of
moscow
commentators report but uh i'm pretty
sure
that in the kremlin of those people who
are responsible for this decision
taking in in in russia this
statement of biden that he wants to meet
putin has been welcomed
it makes russia a more respective
partner it makes russia
look strong on the international agenda
it doesn't isolate russia
the greatest fear of russia has to be
isolated to be completely neglected to
be disrespected by the west
and here by this suggestion of buying to
meet maybe in geneva or in vienna in the
next weeks i think it will happen
and biden will meet uh the russian
leader before he meets
the european leaders in paris in berlin
or in brussels is a cl
as a sign which russia cannot ignore and
i want to come back to that a little bit
later on but let me go now to
uh roman goncharenko and your opening
statement refers to the creeping
annexation
of the eastern uh ukrainian region of
donbass in fact an all-out invasion
is not generally moscow's style until
now
infiltration hybrid warfare have been
the preferred
methods so do you think that is changing
would you expect to see a true military
offensive here
um i would not exclude that but i think
um it's about
eighty percent or seventy percent uh
um muscle flexing uh
and threatening ukraine in the west and
about twenty or thirty percent maybe
military escalation
i don't believe in a full-scale invasion
uh just like we saw in crimea
for several reasons i think um strategic
aim of
putin and russia is to weaken ukraine to
prevent it from joining nato and eu
probably um to divide ukraine into
several states uh
and um to to create new ukraine so so to
say which would be
russia friendly this uh i think that's a
russian
strategy but uh at the moment uh on the
tactical level i think russia is trying
to negotiate with america with
with the new administration of president
biden and this is a
i would say a russian style invitation
uh to a conversation
we should remember that um just a few
weeks ago the u.s president us president
in a in a television interview uh
said yes uh putin is a killer he didn't
say the word killer himself but he
responded positively to the to a
question and this is something which
irritates
vladimir putin very much and i think
it played a certain role in in in the
kremlin's decision to escalate now but
the problem is much deeper i think there
are several problems in eastern ukraine
which putin doesn't like and wants
ukraine to move
and and to yield to russian wishes the
west
is not behaving like russia would like
it to and
maybe also putin sees an opportunity uh
in in a general geopolitical
constellation because in in in the us we
have a new administration which is not
quite strong enough we have in germany
angela merkel
the chancellor who is going yeah and and
it's not clear who will be after her
there is a pandemic in the world the
world is weakened by the
pandemic ukraine is very weak so this is
just a chance and putin is known to be
someone who uses the chances when they
are there
thank you very much and i want to come
back to some of the points that you made
but first
let us take a closer look at what is
going on in eastern ukraine instability
in the donbass region
actually goes back seven years following
the russian annexation of crimea
pro-russian separatists in the eastern
part of the country
seized a large swathe of territory
fighting there began escalating in
february of this year and for weeks now
russia has been deploying additional
troops to its side of the border
according to the ukrainian government
russia has deployed up to 40
000 troops to the border with eastern
ukraine
russian state television reports that
this move is a response to provocations
by ukraine
while russian military maneuvers on the
crimean peninsula annexed by russia
continue both sides are playing with
fire
ukrainian president zielinski wants to
show strength as he visits his troops
what is clear to everyone is that if our
soldiers are attacked if there are
casualties
then we have to fight back
this conjures up memories from 2014 when
russian soldiers were also stationed at
the border
supporting pro-russian separatists in
eastern ukraine who sought independent
status
14 000 people died in the conflict and
there is a living fear that this could
happen again
a previously agreed peace deal has so
far failed to be implemented
we are afraid for our children i have
another five-year-old in kindergarten
how are they supposed to cope we are
afraid of every noise
if there is a loud noise somewhere the
children get scared
and hide is a russian attack on ukraine
imminent
gazina let's drill a little bit deeper
on what we can discern about russia's
strategy here
i actually have seen some commentators
suggesting that an attack
couldn't be imminent simply because the
conditions on the ground
would be so problematic at the moment in
terms of weather
and uh and so on that uh troops would
get bogged down
yeah that's something i read uh too in
april it's not the best month
but you never know i mean nobody
expected in 2014 that russia would
annexate crimea and that it would send
its troops and mercenaries uh to the
donbass so you never know
um i think about the motives there might
be one motor for a real invasion
this concerns uh crimea and
the water supply so right now the only
contact
or connection between the peninsula and
russia
is a bridge the new build bridge and
crimea has a huge water supply
supply problem and maybe this is why
russia would like to have a land
corridor to
crimea but this is speculation and
indeed there are many other motives for
just um
saber wrestling indeed so let's talk
about some of those as well alexander
our report pointed out that ukraine also
has been deploying
additional troops to the region and in
fact president zielenski
rather ostentatiously took a cnn camera
team
with him to the front lines does ukraine
bear at least some responsibility for
this escalation
i think the same part the same
responsibility as russia because ukraine
is also building up its military
presence
at donbass and in my view zilensky
thought that while
president trump ex-president trump was
not interested in ukraine
he may now get more support including
weapons weapon delivery from united
states
he hopes that the united states will
help him maybe
in a certain way to get back on bus and
the crimea
at least he sees his timetable and he
wants to
uh to secure his interest with ukraine's
interests in this in this manner for
russia
the main motive of what they are doing
is to prevent nato expansion
to ukraine and therefore they want to
keep ukraine a split country
they want to threaten also the west that
each each step towards more membership
ukraine and nato
will bring more confrontation of the
west or nato west russia
sorry to sorry to direct if i may
because i think it's not acceptable to
say
that both ukraine and russia are in the
same time
responsible for this maybe new
escalation because
uh president zielenski said that yes we
would like to
defend we will of course defend our land
in case of an aggression
he didn't not say that he would try to
get crimea and the donbass back by
force and on the other hand you have
these many thousands
dozen thousands of thousands of troops
on the russian side so you can't compare
that
let me ask roman goncharenko to come in
on this same point uh
roman you uh said in your opening
statement you cautioned
ukraine to stay calm but going to the
front lines with the cnn camera team
doesn't
exactly fit that description i would say
do you see
ukraine as bearing at least some
responsibility
for provocation and escalation
well i don't see any point in um
i i don't see any proof of ukraine
escalating because
you cannot compare the forces of ukraine
and russia militarily and financially
and what we've seen so far in the
in the years before and then in in the
days and weeks before this escalation
was the
uh wish of the pro-russian separatists
who are backed by russia militarily
um to to to
start a fire i would say and um by
caution in ukraine i mean
ukraine should be very careful not to um
um to create a situation like we had in
georgia in 2008
when we had some weeks of fighting uh
in in in the region of south associate
and then
the georgia decided we will try to
liberate
as they said the president sakashi
really said
that region and russia of course was
nearby
was ready in a standby modus and and
then
the invasion was legitimized so to say
yes
and this is this is what russia maybe
would like to see in ukraine as well
russia would like to see ukraine make a
mistake
and maybe let itself be provoked by by
the fighting of the recent weeks
and this is this is probably the biggest
danger and the biggest challenge for the
ukrainian government but i don't see
any proof or any any evidence that
ukraine
might do that because if you if you take
a cnn camera team with you
you're just trying to show to the world
you're trying to use the media ukrainian
president is a media
media man he's a media um he used to be
a comedian he used to be a television
star
so that's what he does and what he can
what he cannot do is to do anything
militarily
let me ask you this uh the fact is the
conflict zone
uh in eastern ukraine is mainly russian
speaking
and many of its residents now have
russian passports
russia says that if these citizens are
endagent it
must protect them that is a rationale
for military intervention that we have
heard before is it justified
um no it's not but russia
did the preparations and they have
the laws that oblige them even to
protect their citizens
even abroad but um the key question is
whether there is
the danger that they will be um killed
by
nationalists or other people so
aggressive people
this is a narrative that uh russia is
spreading that moscow is spreading by
even comparing the situation in eastern
ukraine
with the schreiber in on the balkans
which
is disgusting uh from my point of view
so
um this is a stretched strategy used by
moscow
and not only now in donbass but it has
been used before
in georgia with abrasion and south
ossetia
in february alexander president
zielenski took measures to silence three
pro-russian
broadcasters in ukraine and also to
sanction the oligarch
who owns them that oligarch happens to
have close
ties to putin is the russian troop build
up partly a message to
zolensky that he went too far in
essentially trying to shut down russian
propaganda machines
i think the message is more to the west
no nato membership of ukraine as i said
before but
indeed i think it is a big mistake of
zeliensky to close down
the three television stations to
broadcast in russia
because still in eastern ukraine and
more people
live in eastern ukraine than in western
ukraine and ukraine
i mean they tend to listen also to
russian programs
and that steers more tension inside the
country then
then brings the escalation so i hope
that
this mistake somehow will be taken back
and what what i think it's tremendously
important is that
putin and zeliensky meet because in in
the normand
for me uh the normandy format or in the
minsk
format uh these meetings with germans
and french
they didn't materialize they didn't
bring more progress
for peace so let's see how it will
develop probably the united states will
now enter the pcp's process
in the minsk after in the minsk process
after the meeting between biden and
putin this will be a game changer in
which way it will be successful that's a
big question
i want to come back i have to um say a
few words about uh those television
channels
um they were broadcasting in ukrainian
uh those three channels but they had
links to russia that's that's for sure
and there are still other channels in
ukraine that broadcast in russian
language and
mostly appeal to the uh ukrainians in
eastern
and uh southern ukraine where people
speak russian still
thank you very much and uh those formats
that you mentioned
normandy minsk and so on these are of
course formats that try to bring
other uh european uh powers as well into
the conversation in hope
of getting a real peace process going
but so far
with uh notably limited results so let's
talk about the international aspect
of this conflict and briefly if you
would uh
in fact ukraine is literally caught
between
the fronts of old military blocks the
western defense alliance nato
which ukraine would like to join and
russia
russian president putin is celebrating
the seventh anniversary of the
annexation of crimea
the strategically important peninsula
located in the black sea
despite the sanctions imposed by the
west putin has not changed his policy
russian soldiers are once again
stationed on the ukrainian border
and once again they are waiting on help
from the west which was discussed at a
nato meeting for foreign ministers in
brussels
we're now seeing the largest
concentration
of russian forces on ukraine's borders
since
2014 and that is a deep concern
not only to to ukraine but to the united
states and indeed
to many of our allies and partners the
united states has actually sent
warships to monitor the situation russia
is responding with a military maneuver
[Music]
what is the us doing with its ships and
soldiers who are constantly engaging in
some kind of activity outside of nato's
borders in ukraine
thousands of kilometers away from their
own territory
this question has not been answered
it also raises the question how far will
nato go to help ukraine
and let me put that question straight
away to you gazina
the russian buildup has provoked strong
words
from the u.s and nato but would they
follow up with action ukraine of course
is not
a member of nato so there is no treaty
obligation there
there is not and if you mean by a strong
reaction if uh
ukraine will be a member of nato very
soon though it won't of course it will
not
and it hasn't even been granted the
membership action plan
but um usa are talking about stronger
sanctions and this is something
what might really happen like uh cutting
off
russia from the swift system or
um the banking international transfer
system something like that
roman chancellor mackel has called on
the eu to react to events in eastern
ukraine resolutely and
unequivocally those were her words how
could
the eu and nato support ukraine
short of sending in troops should and
could they send additional weapons
uh should they in fact speed up the
timetable for a ukrainian membership in
nato what do you think
well at the moment i think um most
things have been done so
um there were strong words and uh
weapons were sold to ukraine in the past
years though
i don't think ukrainian army needs
something which which much might change
the situation on the ground of course it
would like to have
patriot systems but i don't think the us
will will
go that far because that will provoke
russia of course
what what might be needed if we see an
escalation and and
a new um military conflict and which
will lead to
ukraine losing more territory then i
think
europe and the west um in general should
think about
uh strengthening or um
building new creating new sectoral
sanctions against
sectors of russian economy because this
have has shown we have seen it in the
past years
the most the strongest instrument to
influence russia
not just uh visa and and then travel
bans but
uh sectoral sanctions but only if we see
an escalation at the moment
we are not there yet let me stay with
the question of sanctions and uh
and ask you alexander the u.s and the eu
have actually enacted multiple rounds of
sanctions against russia
in past years not only for the actions
in crimea but also for the poisoning of
navalny alexey navalny the opposition uh
the politician and also former spy
sergey skipal the u.s is apparently
about to impose
new sanctions for cyber warfare
and interference in the u.s elections so
does any of this
any of these sanctions have any real
influence on moscow's behavior
not at all and i think that we will have
a completely different agenda
russia and the eu will start cooperating
on
the vaccine sputnik v for europe
and i also think that for the americans
the main
adversary on the global stage is not
russia but china
and therefore biden doesn't want to risk
sending more troops to ukraine or
weapons to ukraine and bind
all his military apparatus and military
machine in europe
whether and neglect the situation which
can
tomorrow occur in china but clearly
biden uh is willing to impose additional
sanctions because it seems he's about to
do so uh gazina what do you think how
strong is the u.s resolve
to support ukraine we have heard that
those warships that were supposedly
going to be transferred
dispatched to the black sea turkey says
that deployment has been canceled
yeah exactly but uh in fact uh the u.s
never said that they openly that they
send it so there's
uh very much is unclear and the only
sources
we used and and were that turkish
the turkish state said that there would
come these warships so
um i think it's a very clever reaction
by biden by
offering a dialogue and at the same time
giving clear advice that we will do
something
roman one sentence if you would is it
time for germany to
finally put the north stream gas
pipeline project
with russia on ice
i think this will be decided by the new
german german government in
in autumn after the parliamentary
elections and we should stop talking
about it because it's not uh
possible to do it at the moment thank
you very much to you for being with us
from bonn
thanks to the others in the studio and
all of you out there
thanks for joining us see you soon
you